depuis six mois cette polémique ne fait
que te suivront va rappeler 1 c'était
voilà sur la chanteuse o'shea et c'est
vrai que voilà même moi je te le dis
tout cela dit c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué voilà ce que tu as dit sur
cette chanteuse s'était très vexant pour
elle en plus j'adore cet artiste est
est ce que tu sais que tu es aujourd'hui
tu dis j'ai fait une énorme connerie
oui évidemment je regrette mais parce
que l'erreur est humaine encore une fois
de plus mes mecs tu te rends compte que
pour elle sans mes victimes moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de peine aussi parce que de
l'uar fait de la peine ça m'a aussi
meurtri aussi parce que je voulais pas
lui faire de la peine à ses parents ou à
sa grand mère évidemment c'est un
dérapage c'est à dire j'étais à la 4éme
itau de la journée j'en avais marre ma
mère et à l'hôpital pour un cancer enfin
c'était compliqué et puis j'ai mis le
mauvais qualificatif parce que le mot
effrayant effectivement moi je le dis
tout le temps déjà dans le dans la vie
un cergy fait une chaleur effrayante la
chaleur n'a pas de visage
son album s'appelle étoiles flippante
bon j'ai pris un mauvais synonyme mais
vous rendez compte flippant vous êtes
mis à sa place un moment je pense que
vous avez dû vous mettre à la 23e fois
que je souhaite aussi je vous jure que
c'est vrai fabien je pense à ça et je me
dit la pauvre c'est vrai que ça a dû
être un traumatisme en mai sur lui c'est
vraiment une chanteuse que j'adore qui
était venu nous voir ici et je la trouve
voilà je la trouve très talentueux j'ai
nommé mais évidemment je suis d'ailleurs
j'ai pas manqué de saluer son talent
dans cette même solution d'ailleurs mais
surtout jeune fille de 27 ans donc on l
partiquement du même âge mais un gaucher
et et je trouve que bien sûr que c'est
ce qu'elle sera dit votre fille est ce
que je ne savais pas belle et elle
prenait aussi un peu des insultes il ya
les dommages collatéraux avec tout
l'entourage 1 on ne sachant vous avez
vous êtes passé par là d'ailleurs avec
une affaire jean-josé vous aussi la
surveillance et on sait ce que c'est et
non mes skis à ce que je trouve quand
même
moi j'ai beaucoup de peine de tout ça
parce que je voulais pas faire ça vous
qui me connaissaient depuis des années
c'est pas mon métier de seul coup
d'insultés légende c'est pas votre style
c'est pas bout de six ou non mais bien
sûr bien sûr j'aime utiliser le move est
synonyme c'est une erreur je l'ait
reconnu je m'en suis excusé ce que je
regrette c'est de la compta non mais moi
ce que je regrette justement cyril c'est
ça c'est l'absence de dialogue mais elle
ne peut pas comment on peut jamais
prendre bien sûr quelle a été ma bien
c'est très dur et des vignes non mais
bien sûr bien sûr mais essayé de la
contacter veux pas vous parler non
mélangés à comprendre la peau noire mais
je n'ai pas essayé de la contacter du
nahd accord n'est pas ici d'un continent
mais comme ça enflait sur les réseaux
sociaux ça enfle s en fait on était au
bout de quinze jours à 400 mille
messages entre twitter instagram
facebook et cetera à ce moment là on est
contacté par la police judiciaire parce
qu'au-delà 400000 y pense qu'à une
anomalie sur votre compte je monte je la
990 mais le message ce qui est énorme
alors il ya au milieu de ses 900 ça
c'était en 1990 mines faut sauver un
message de mort en
1940 mais le message insultes 1 j'ai eu
sept cent cinquante mille insultes sur
les 980 non 750 mille messages de
soutien un de soutien et 150000 message
d' insulte dont 130 et une menace de
mort c'est à dire qu'on s'aperçoit qu'en
fait il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
compris dans la vie et qui sont aussi
sur les réseaux sociaux ce que je
voulais dire je condamnerai deux époques
maladroitement certes mais je comparais
deux époques où on posait la question
l'alaric d'influencé tels la réussite
enfin bref je veux pas revenir sur ce
dossier non je sais on va parler là
dessus mais il est vrai que moi voilà et
je vous le dis au chili c'est vrai que
là pouf moi je crois que vous l'aviez
c'est là sa mort mais je comprends qu'il
faille pas vous parler parce que elle a
dû être extrêmement blessé et c'est bon
je vous dire le seul truc à moi c'est qu
en chine et je le dis franchement je la
trouve extrêmement mignonne mais oui
mais c'est grandiose donc je pense qu'en
fait je vous dire en corse aurait été
vraiment quelqu'un vraiment qui a un
physique des compliqué je penserai temps
combiné mois au moins aussi gelé vue
elle est venue ici aller elle est très
belle et la sueur jolie fille vraiment
je l'aï bien sûr bien sûr et c'est vrai
que géraldine vous avez effectué le truc
à la con selon c'est vrai que c'est une
sortie de route catastrophe ce sera vous
l'avez dit c'est un dérapage après vous
vous excusez et après en découle une
mise à mort médiatique c'est ça alors
nous ici on n'arrête pas de dire qu'on a
droit à une deuxième exactement que
quand on a payé sa peine c'est vrai a
purgé sa peine on une deuxième chance et
l'a visiblement on n'a pas droit à une
deuxième c'est ce que c'est ça oui oui
mais c'est un dénommé réseaux sociaux
c'est la pensée horizontale comme aux
états unis c'est à dire c'est des gens
qui nous disent toute la journée que le
feu ça brûle et clos ça mouille c'est ça
les réseaux sociaux donc toute une bien
pensants se met derrière ça et d'un seul
coup on est là alors on se dit mais
attendez j'ai tué personne je suis pas
un violeur jeu peintures d'enfants je
suis pas avoir donné mais il a quand
même duré convient pas à l'époque on
fait alors donc vous êtes là vous avez
la gueule qui ne convient pas à l'époque
qui ne conduisent c'est presque un
délicieux rapidement vers la russie vous
avez raison vous êtes blanc vous avez
plus de 50 ans vous êtes hétéro
oui mais bien sûr là bas mais je suis
d'accord oui alors j'aime moi au départ
il est une sortie de route et
je vais vous dire gérald est une
personne n'était à l'abri
moi ce qui me chagrine sincèrement je
prends la parole c'est que on est en
train de devoir avoir de la peine pour
l'attaquant et moi ça me fait chier
clairement parce que à un moment donné
là c'est quand même toi l'attaquant
fabien c'est toi qui a atteint
volontairement involontairement mais
quand même enfin tu es pas débile takam
dit des mots je te remercie laisser des
mots très forts et c'est vraiment je
verrais bien tous les deux oui moi je
les adore ça a été mon seul nom
mon voisin pendant des mois et des
années dorées on s'adore mais moi ce qui
me fâche c'est que là on peut pas te
plaindre parce que tu a attaqué une
personne cje de vente pas être sur son
physique non mais je demande pas je
demande parce qu'on me comprenne non
j'aurais aimé ce que j'aurais simplement
aimé c'est qu'en fait celui-là contact
et tu fasse tout pour essayer de la
joindre et que tu t'excuses devant elle
parce qu'en fait tu te situes utilisent
encore les réseaux pour t'excuser se
dire qu'on tourne en rond j'espère que
c'est que les réseaux les réseaux les
réseaux et après la ccc là il ya un an
mais moi j'y lis pas les raisons mais
aussi parce que tu t'excuses uniquement
sur les réseaux mais non non non non ça
soit les faire sortir des réseaux il
faut se mettre dans la vraie vie et
s'excuser dans la vraie vie ça ce que
les gars la vraie vie c'est ce qui
compte le plus mais alors je vais te
remercier les gens hostiles séparés
alors si les gens refusent il ya parce
que dans tout ça ça a été un super
mental is est quand même j'ai pas si
vous en êtes où se persuade mais ce que
vous avez essayé de la contacter non bon
alors lorsque la morquenne sinon j'ai
appelé j'ai appelé son attaché de presse
que je connais bien par ailleurs
sa manageuse apparemment c'est aussi sa
compagne dans la vie et apparemment il y
avait une espèce de blocus non non on
veut surtout pas parler bon donc
ok de fleurs avec un petit mot pour dire
mais deuxième mois son adresse ça semble
prêt après la laddh non mais enfin on
parle aussi c'est sur le fond mais sur
la forme ça légitime pas les menaces de
mort non plus
je pense qu'à 10 pour rien parce que je
vais vous dire non mais elle n'est pour
rien dans cette exagération c'est
malheureux mais elle est pour rien parce
que je pense que les gens ne mesurent
pas un moment donné la force des réseaux
quand il ya une haine ici il ya une
personne qui est extrêmement
intelligente c'est bernard montiel parce
que vous n'avez été comptés alors ça
c'est un vrai super c'est pour les
autres
[Rires]
mais je le devrais il est applaudi
ça est très bien vous n'êtes pas gentil
syrie vers la mesure où les raisons sont
vianney de mer je voulais quand même lui
rendre hommage parce que il a été
contacté par un chanteur très connu je
vais pas donner le nom pour essayer de
me charger un peu plus il a tout de
suite éloigner le dossier il a dit moi
je ne mange pas de ce pain là c'est vrai
il s'est pas mis dans la meute mais
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs tous ici je ne
suis pas certain vous y soyez mais dans
la meute sur internet
c'est à dire antalis qu'on a pensé de du
doigt la rue et se dire on dit aussi des
amis c'est là aussi que c'est une
connerie toutefois on se le dit et c'est
vrai que voilà c'est ça et c'est vrai
que là moi j'étais j'ai en plus c'est
vraiment une artiste j'adore [ __ ]
witham à sa mamie hyper mal ce que
vraiment j'adore cet artiste et c'est
vrai que voilà je me suis dit pour elle
c'est ça doit être un traumatisme mais
bon voilà après ce qu'est ce que disait
géraldine c'est vrai que ça donne ça
n'excuse pas les menaces mais
derrière les américains sens alors moi
je connais très bien aussi évidemment
franchement elle a été profondément
blessée
raisons personnelles qui date de l'an
son enfance
en revanche tout ce qui était tombé sur
la gueule après sa non c'est affreux tu
méritais pas ça du tout soyons clairs on
peut tu t'es excusé et elle même n'a
jamais souhaité sa vie d'ailleurs elle
n'a jamais relayé quoi que ce soit
jamais elle a été très doux sa compagne
elle ont été impeccables
franchement et il est vrai que quelqu'un
nous avait contactés pour se charger on
ne l'a pas fait qu un chanteur ouais bon
d'annoncer le nom est à lancer non non
non c'est qui si fabien le dit non moi
c'est bernard
n'avait pas le dire pourquoi pas
français si ça vient le disent et c'est
très bien non tu as le concerne très
directement à moi donc en fait le prénom
mais non mes skis ski ce qui est
important de rappeler
non non je vous apprendrai cette nuit là
pour vous
oui mais parce que vous savez un moment
donné quand vous avez une casserole tout
le monde sait ça ici parce qu'on a tous
plus ou moins eu des casseroles vos
meilleurs ennemis se mutualisent
ensemble mais et d'un seul coup tout le
monde s'acharne sur la bête vous savez
ça sert il aussi
c'est vrai que c'est l'effet de meute
c'est l'effet de meute et et alors
heureusement ce qui moi ce qui m'a
sauvée de cette situation
c'est que j'ai été soutenu par des gens
quand même relativement important aussi
très important des programmateurs des
producteurs des artistes des animateurs
télé etc c'est à dire donc ça ça donne
chaud au coeur après le troupeau allez
vous avez été mis à l'écart de tout va
bien après ça vous plaît non non pas du
tout non non non non pas du tout vous
avez compris je suis un type aux
activités vous avez arrêté la radio
alors j'étais suspendu de contrat avec
leurs copains bah oui une suspension
provisoire ouais mais bon ça lattmann
pas repris enfin moment là ça n'a pas
repris la chanson bizarre quand ça dure
18 ans et
définitive je veux rajouter quand on est
salarié c'est compliqué quand même
d'accord oui mais bon donc pour
l'instant suspension et personne n'a
écrit n'y europe 1 personne ni la drh ni
le service juridique ah oui d'accord
c'est quand même étonnant mon avocat
juste et fans loisy me disait il me dit
mais c'est quand même étonnant vous êtes
salarié d'un groupe on vous téléphone
pour vous faire une une suspension
provisoire ce que je trouve ça tout à
fait normal et et descend mais personne
ne vous écris parce qu'en fait ça c'est
pas passé à l' europe 1 c'est
contractuellement c'est très difficile
de
comprendre on prend de l'humeur spécial
humeur tenu à travailler normalement oui
oui après ce que j'écris mes livres
accor jour j'ai mon contrat à mon
éditeur n'a surtout pas me pas rendu mon
contrat j'interviens régulièrement
encore sur des chaînes de télé 2 voilà
d'infos
je monte une exposition sur la chanson
française très importante pour l'année
prochaine mais juste un jeu enfin il ya
rien il ya des métiers moi j'ai reprise
blacklisté non non parce que alors c'est
ça se fait peut-être goethe est le
ressentir dans les prochaines maintenant
vous savez c'est pas le chou pas le
premier à qui ça arrive un non plus vous
êtes senti comment quand vous avez tout
ce déferlement vous avez quand même
manger vous dormez mal j'étais très
angoissée et vous êtes vous avez
culpabiliser pour o'shea oui parce que
je ne voulais pas j'avais j'avais peur
qu'elle fasse des bêtises parce que
parce que je me souciais en tant que
papa je me suis dit c'est pas bien parce
que je voulais pas faire ça sincèrement
je voulais pas faire et j'ai et j'ai eu
peur pour elle parce que voilà alors moi
je m'en foutais un peu de moi je les ai
bon ben j'ai dit une connerie et j'ai
fait présenter mes excuses mais ça
m'inquiétait et en même temps je sais
pas si vous l'avez tous vécu ici c'est à
dire qu'on s'aperçoit dans la rue c'est
pas du tout internet parce que là j'ai
pas suis pas sorti de chez moi pendant
deux jours et demi à peine j'ai dit je
vais quand même sortir il y avait un
type qui est en train de garer son
scooter dans ma rue en face il fait voir
fabien lecoeuvre à chatou dit ça y est
ça commence je croyais qu'il allait à
m'insulter dit ouais je suis d'accord
avec vous un jeudi mais non c'est parce
que je voulais dire non parce que non
mais c'est à dire qu'on s'aperçoit non
mais ce qui est important de rappeler
c'est que les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
la rue un régime bien moi je croisais
des gens non mais c'est important de le
dire est qu'en m'excuser à ce point
n'ont pas jamais et moi d'un seul coup
je pensais que j'allais agressé dans la
rue par des gens pas du tout c'est à
dire que le courage quand vous avez les
gens en face c'est pas le même que
derrière l'écran auxerre mais même ça ça
se passe nous on pense surtout voilà à
la hausse il a vécu bien sûr bah oui
est-ce que son fou rire et en vous
entendant voilà vous êtes aussi
intelligent et ce qui a pas chez vous
une forme même d'opportunisme dans
l'excusent un noir que non non non oui
mais non vous pose vraiment la question
non parce qu'on pense qu à ça non mais
est ce que oui mais moi je veux vous
poser la question les yeux dans les yeux
est ce qu'en fait vous excusez pas et
vous ne vous êtes pas excuser parce que
ça promet des proportions non et que en
fait ce que vous avez dit est ce que
vous ne le pensiez pas vraiment est ce
que gilles ya pas que le mot effrayant
vous êtes bien le reste aussi mais j'ai
analysé oui mais mais si vous êtes
sincère quand est-ce que vous avez vous
avez des enfants oui franchement quand
on est père de famille moi je suis on
peut pas je peux pas me donner raison à
moi j'ai dérapé j'ai dérapé
je suis malheureux pour elle aussi parce
que c'est pas bien bon même si l'on sur
buzz et avec ça un tri mentaliser la
maison disent que machin tout ça c'est
parti dans tous les sens bon moi vous
m'avez pas vu à la télévision pendant
quatre mois c'est normal
non non c'est non faire de tes insultes
quelque chose de commercial elle fait ce
qu'elle veut
non non mais moi je ne voulais pas faire
de plateau parce que j'ai été contacté
non mais non mais non peuvent entendre
quand même vous n'allez pas vous
conduire les médecins cadres sacrés l'an
dernier morgan et moi j'ai pas voulu je
me suis mis volontairement à l'écart
aussi j'ai pas voulu
parce que parce que je trouvais ça
malsain de venir c'était trop tôt là il
s'est passé six mois kelly s'il vous
plaît je peux m'exprimer parce que sinon
vous avez la même attitude sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire qu'il ya
une absence de dialogue non mais oh
combien de légende et victimisées la
plaque ans et servait juste nommé en
fait jamais très bien parce que juste
pour qu'on vienne sur le truc et après
on va on va passer à autre chose mais
c'est vrai que vous êtes excusés comme
des rallyes nous c'est vrai qu'on est
bon pour la deuxième chance mais en fait
là ce qui se passe c'est que il peut
avoir d un antagonisme entre deux
personnes mais là le problème c'est que
là elle la pauvre elle a rien demandé
bah oui elle est tranquille chez elle
elle ce point d'une norme script de raté
c'est vrai mais la peau qui va qui va
être qui veulent compléter la des
boussoles concret traumatisant et qui
aida débouche donné sa famille ses
proches et donc c'est ça le truc c'est
qu'elle elle a rien demandé sinon quand
elle avait dit oui bien sûr vous et on
est dans un cas la layan mais moi je
vais vous expliquer après parce que il
ya eu un rebondissement début juillet
quand fabien marsaud plus connu sous le
nom de grand corps malade a fait une
chanson qui s'appelle les gens beaux
c'est à dire qu'il a pris ma voix mes
mots il a fait un duo ce qui est plutôt
bien fait bien sûr bon mais alors il a
relancé la polémique oui mais bon il l'a
fait pour elle et si moi je trouve que
c'est super ce qu'il a fait grand corps
malade suis désolé je te jure fabien
ouais c'est magnifique pour être ses
deux copines à lui il lui a fait un
titre c'est génial c'est une copine à
lui mais il a vu sa copine mal c'est
normal d'aller l'aider je suis désolé
fabien tu aurais fait pareil avec un
poste utilisé oui il a
encore une chanson certes moi le jour
choisi ni interviews je pensais pas que
j'enregistre un indice quand même non
même si
y'a rien il a fait le plus beau truc que
peut faire un ami pour une copine riz
est dans la détresse en crète jamais
pensé est ce qu'il a pensé aussi et toi
c'est sa défense n'ont même pas bien des
points qui l'on se retrouve pas le droit
est là est là elle a rien demandé l
arrêt demandé s'en prendre à eux louis
femmes mathieu non mais là vous êtes
super par don kelly je te souhaite qu'il
y de ne jamais de douala aurait dérapé
il a pilé billy pas en train de dire
dont il a dérapé l'a dit bien sûr si
j'ai fait une connerie maintenant l
effet reconnu mois fabien les falaisiens
fabrice tarrit public à la hauteur à la
hauteur de lacaugne insu lady exact ça
fait 30 ans qu'il dit du bien de tous
les artistes c'est vrai peut aussi on
peut aussi reconnaître qu'on peut tous
dira journée en me conneries vannes et
ce jour-là kelly j'espère que on serait
un petit peu soutenu il a fait ses
excuses voilà publiquement il faut aussi
dire quelque chose par dont un à l'air
juste un tout petit peu sur des réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui instagram et on le
sait si on a trois heures de direct moi
je sais pas pour vous mais quand je
rentre chez moi que j'allume j'ai un
moment de stress je vois 45 50 messages
j'ai un moment de stress à chaque fois
qu'ils montent je ne sais pas ce qu'il
va y avoir il ya des insultes et des
menaces et à chaque fois yassa et vous
avez envie de marquer votre [ __ ]
instagram mais vous pouvez parler les
risques dans toutes les chaînes
maintenant vous le dis les directeurs de
programmes d vous arrivez quelque part
on vous dit terrebonne followers ou pas
là c'est comme ça qu'on va aussi travaux
aujourd'hui quelle est ta valeur
qu'elles évaluent j'ai une anecdote oui
ma première télé que j'ai fait mathieu
c'était avec toi
ça s'appelait le mad mad d'accord jamais
je suis arrivé en plateau non mais je
suis arrivée au plateau tu peux aller
sur youtube et la première chose que tu
m'as dit c'est pas bonjour c'est tu as
combien de followers sur instagram à
tu vois
ils vont tous les noeuds
je n'ai jamais soutenu femmes et de
coeur
sa mère tu veux te dise la vérité tu
fais un ami et j'étais mal pour toi
parce que j'étais mal pour o'shea dirais
que j'ai surtout que vous avez vécu la
même chose non mais non faut me lâcher
avec ça ça rien à voir je vais pas faire
un dérapage comme sa famille je te le
dis ça n'a rien à voir moi je suis pas
digne d'un truc sur une arme mais je
parle pas du dérapage jeu par jeu par
des conséquences ou et moi j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] moi les conseillerez vous en
parlez dans votre livre mais oui mais
moi je m'en fous des conséquences je
vais le dire moi c'est ok quand tu
parlais d'un animal tout à l'heure moi
pour bouffer il faut être beaucoup
mais j'en ai rien à [ __ ] moi je moi je
veux dire c'est bon au contraire plus on
m'a dit j'aime ça mais je vais te dire
là là le truc c'est pas ça qui m'a bien
sûr fabien sait que un je t'aime
énormément tu le sais et ça m'a mis mal
pour toi parce que je t'aime et quand tu
vois un ami dans la détresse ça te fait
mal et 2 j'étais très mal parce que
o'shea jeu l'adorent et que je ne
pouvais pas te défendre c'est que c'est
quand un ami mon âme qui va bien sûr qui
est un de ces incroyables c'est affreux
quand un pote que tu aimes avec qui tu
as vécu des moments extraordinaires et
qui vais les conneries et était dans la
merde et tu dis [ __ ] il est
indéfendable c'est vrai en plus une
artiste que j'adore vraiment je te jure
j'ai bâton même sort était une artiste
même poste c'est indéfendable vraiment
je te jure même moi j'ai très très mal
vécu ce moment et je vienne ce soir mais
je sais que tu es tout ça parce que je
voulais te le dire aussi basse que celle
j'étais mal parce que les choix là
j'étais dans un truc ou je sais pas quoi
faire et il cherche et je me suis dit
quel con je te dis on peut faire une
connerie la vie c'est humain voilà on
est des êtres humains je crois que à un
moment donné voilà c'est comme ça c'est
vrai c'est vraiment cauchy j'espère et
je suis libre aux chiites le magnifique
et je suis toujours que le pense
vraiment je trouve qu'elle a un style
incroyable qu'elle est très jolie elle
est trop chou mais vraiment et c'est le
seul truc en fait aux pays pauvres à
graulhet c'est que si elle était
vraiment ce qu'avait dit fabien a même
été tellement magnifique elle était
venue sur le plateau elle est route
rouge bien sûr o'shea est vraiment
j'adore cette j'adore même même
physiquement j'avais craqué pour le show
jure que c'est vrai alain still de fous
et voilà ce qu'est ce qui est important
de rappeler au mieux tout ça parce que
c'est une expérience intéressante pour
l'être humain que nous sommes tous oui
c'est à dire qu'on s'aperçoit que on a
supprimé la peine de mort en france et
dieu merci mais mais elles existent sur
les réseaux sociaux mais complètement
mais quel que soit le sujet politique
chansons présentation émission miss
france peu importe la peine de mort
existe encore et c'est ça qui est quand
même incroyable ce déferlement cette
haine cette application ces gens qui se
cachent à des pseudo enfin c'est quand
même hallucinant clarix merci avec ça
non merci fabien d'avoir été là et
fabien j'espère tu vas pouvoir
rencontrer au chic tu vas pouvoir lui
dire tout bien
fait qu'oracle a trouvé je vous remercie
pas vraiment à bout une belle lettre une
belle lettre je vivrai je ferai un très
beau texte mal à parce que franchement
elle le mérite et mais bien sûr